[Music]
Rhianna as getting more candid than ever
the singer has been the target of fat
shamers will now hear what she has to
say
now I look fat I got double chin fat
phase and your cheeks looking like baby
cheeks Suda's garlic boom
that's Rihanna fully unashamed of her
weight gain saying quote I know when I'm
having a fat day and when I've lost
weight I accept all of the body
I'm very realistic when I look in the
mirror I know if I'm in shape out of
shape if I got zits I've got dark
circles I'm not like blanks and myself
and I'm not feeling bad about that
either beautiful this finger is Vogue's
June covergirl Rihanna reveals she
definitely wants to be a mom someday but
worries now that she's turned 30 quote
should I be freezing my eggs what's got
babies on the brain well it could be
Rihanna's year long relationship with
Saudi billionaire Hassan Jamil Rihanna
says quote I'm happy and he's worth it
for her to take personal time away from
work to be with him as for her
relationship now with her ex Drake she's
someone I've been in love with since I
was 22 years old three recalls that
moment at the 2015 VMAs uncomfortable
she adds we don't have a friendship now
but we're not enemies either it is what
it is
[Music]
[Applause]